une loi qui est très ambitieuse
puisqu'elle est destiné à prendre en
compte cette évolution en effet à
l'heure actuelle on assiste à la réunion
comme ailleurs à vieillissement de la
population le pari de la réunion c'est
de mieux vieillir en famille est de
permettre à ces gramoune de pouvoir être
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
jusqu'à leurs derniers jours et votre
travail aujourd'hui c'est de former des
agents du département accompagné et
aller vers cet objectif
c'est ça et est de donner la possibilité
de se mettre en synergie
parce que nous avons mis en oeuvre avec
la directrice de l'autonomie et les
agents du cnfpt
c'est donc un travail sur ce décryptage
mais c'est aussi le recueil de
propositions opérationnelles de manière
à ce qu'ils puissent tous ceux
devenir partie prenante dans cette
démarche qui était un pari extrêmement
important à relever pour la réunion
alors une augmentation de l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie qui permet le
maintien à domicile ce qui est très
important dans la société de la réunion
qui est très attaché au suivi de ces
anciens également une aide aux aidants
les aidant ce sont les personnes de la
famille qui prenne en compte ces
personnes âgées qui sont en grande
difficulté qui doivent aussi être épaulé
par les services du département dans le
cadre notamment du gip et qui prend en
compte ce temps de répit pour les
personnes âgées et leurs aidants